Janet's and Pennsylvania hi Janet how
are you hey Dave great to talk to you
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up um well I'm having a
morality problem as Kelly just said my
mother is the master of guilt trips and
over the years between me and my two
siblings she has anytime that she's ever
spent money for us or we've caused her
you know some kind of financial low it's
been held over our head for years in
ways like you know to manipulate us to
do things the way she wanted to so I've
tried over the years you know watching
my sister my older sister go through
this to make sure that I didn't you know
called her any undue debt like I
insisted on paying for part of my
wedding I insisted on paying for part of
my college and now once we just got into
a big blowout the other night because
we're family was talking about you know
well all the things that have happened
over the years and my mother's like oh
yeah well we paid for you know we paid
all that money for your college and then
even you didn't finish it and I was like
well mom that was you know what we
agreed on at the time I would pay the
five thousand you were going to pay ten
we pay for half of our wedding all this
stuff is starting to come back and I
just I'm just so frustrated Dave and I
just want to know what what how shot
obligated should I feel should I cut my
mom a check and just you know say leave
gonna leave it alone you know at this
point how obligated should I feel is to
pay back the step is to debts
they're not debts there were gifts from
her it was the deal you have zero
obligation she has a problem you don't
okay she just I don't know where to go
from here
well I mean she's just being a
manipulative jerk and you just have to
realize that's what you're dealing with
and you have to set yourself emotionally
aside from that and just look at your
head and say there goes mom again you
know because I work you told me at the
start of the conversation she's a
manipulative jerk and she does this all
the time to other family members so you
tried to avoid it and now you
shock that you couldn't avoid it mm-hmm
don't be shocked now she does this to
everybody who will let her and the trick
is just don't let her and the way you
don't let her is you don't argue about
it because you're not going to change
her there's no reason to art you're not
gonna argue her down you just stand back
and look at her and shake your head and
go oh there you go again you know yes I
was ready to cut her a check my hon all
discussion just cuz you got my aura
panel in you were of and you were under
the stupid assumption it was going to
make her stop being a manipulator
well you're writing her a check does not
cause her to suddenly be a whole person
she's crazier than a bean girl yes yeah
I guess I'm sure part of it is you know
her frustration because they haven't
made that financial a day in their lives
that's horrible
the only way on why it becomes your
problem is if you decide it's your
problem
and when you got mad and got your
feelings hurt you made it into your
problem it's not your problem you call
its purpose I just needed to hear that
from someone else's that's really what
I've been telling myself over the years
that I spent and guess myself after this
time I'm like maybe I should just pay
her back I guess she got she got she got
the knife in little deeper this time
yeah gotcha the heart got to the heart a
little bit
they hurt one it hurt and it's your mom
you know so but the problem is is that
she's a manipulator and you got hang on
I'm going to have Kelly send you a copy
of a book called boundaries by dr. Henry
cloud because your family doesn't have
any and you probably need to install
some build the wall yeah there you go
it needs some boundaries this is the
deck of Ramsay show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]